[Musique]
alexandre barrelet bonjour et bienvenu
merci à montigny le bretonneux au web to
you pour le café politique alors on vous
connaît assez peu on vous a vu notamment
lors des derniers scrutins législatifs
aux étiez engagé dans la campagne dans
les yvelines vous êtes le président du
rpf dans le département le rassemblement
pour la france mouvement fondé en 1992
et selon ses statuts il entend défendre
la nation française son identité sa
culture et ses traditions dans le
respect des valeurs gaullistes
d'indépendance et de souveraineté
populaire
alors en quoi vous vous démarquez de la
droite plus classiques comme les
républicains par exemple je dirais que
d'une part on reste dans la prolongation
des républicains puisqu'on est
aujourd'hui je vais dire un des
partenaires des républicains au même
titre que d'autres forces républicaines
ou que d'autres partis politiques
c'est vrai que nous nous étions là
j'avais à dire peut-être présent un
petit peu avant les républicains serait
avec nous aujourd'hui on n'est plus sûr
de la souveraineté au niveau des
entreprises la souveraineté par exemple
au niveau du numérique au niveau de
certaines données puisque c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a tendance à trop
regarder ce qu'ils soient en europe de
voir les allemands qui bafoue les règles
européennes pour ce privilégier leurs
propres marchés et nous la france qui
suivent ont bêtement les applications
qui ne sécurisons pas assez notre marché
donc comme albert pf est aussi là pour
rajouter un petit peu de souverainistes
pour dire que c'est très bien
effectivement libéralisme et mais qu'il
faut aussi aujourd'hui être
à côté des préoccupations des français
faire attention effectivement au niveau
des entreprises au niveau de la sécurité
nationale au niveau de l'agriculture au
niveau de l'écologie c'est vrai que
c'est des termes aujourd'hui qui sont
lâchés par la droite traditionnelle
donc c'est pas pourquoi c'est vrai que
l'écologie aujourd'hui c'est un mot
tabou à droite nous au niveau du rpf bas
c'est quelque chose qui est une rame en
sacerdoce c'est cette une défense parce
que le rpf est présent dans toute la
france avec des vraiment des
problématiques qui sont propres à chaque
région et je pense que la droite
en tout cas ça du rpr peut s'associer
des actions environnementales les
défendre et surtout de montrer
effectivement le souverainisme au niveau
de ses actions parce que aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'on met beaucoup l'accent
sur l'europe
j'aimerais bien qu'on leur met un petit
peu plus sur la france les républicains
ont néanmoins qu'ils changent de visage
avec l'arrivée de laurent wauquiez
satisfaite cette victoire tout à fait le
rpf avait soutenu la candidature de
laurent wauquiez récemment j'avais
travaillé aussi avec virginie calmels ce
aurélien véron et cargill trop connu la
montée les universités de la liberté est
un pôle très libérale entreprenariale
mon pied dans en parfaite adéquation
avec ce que défend le rpf aujourd'hui
mais également ce que défend le f qui
est un mouvement entrepreneurs à venir
france avec son père entrepreneur avec
fillon a reproché à forces républicaines
donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes satisfaits parce que je pense que
laurent wauquiez c'est un visage assez
rassurant pour la population quelqu'un
qui comprend qu effectivement
aujourd'hui faut mettre au coeur du
débat
le gaullisme et puis également la partie
libéralisme je pense qu'aujourd'hui faut
qu'on arrive à trouver un mariage entre
ces deux parties je pense que
aujourd'hui on a fait le bon choix en
votant cas en désignant laurent wauquiez
comme présent des républicains hier
qu'il faut se couper des centristes
je pense qu'il faut se couper des
centristes les centristes aujourd'hui
ont un positionnement qui soit est trop
proche de mes d'emmanuel macron
on l'a remarqué pendant toute la
campagne pour moi aujourd'hui la droite
doit être avec la droite
c'est comme ça qu'elle a toujours
fonctionné j'allais dire du temps de
jacques chirac du temps aussi du général
de gaulle la droite voilà c'est la
droite est ce qu'elle va se rapprocher
de l'extrême droite le front national
qui a aussi allumé une reconstruction
absolument pas d'extrême droite comme
d'extrême gauche
pour moi ce sont les ennemis à abattre
des gens qui parlent de la destruction
de la france qui va les opposer les
français entre eux on n'est pas je vais
dire dans une france productrice mais on
est toujours dans la comparaison
négative on est toujours à montrer du
doigt ce qui dérange ou avant de faire
sa propre analyse
pour moi le front national est un ennemi
que ce soit au niveau du rpf on l'a
toujours combattu et les républicains je
pense qu'on fera exactement la même
chose d'ailleurs virginie calmels a
rappelé il est hors de question de faire
le moindre rapprochement avec les front
national alors de la présidentielle vous
aviez soutenu françois fillon qui depuis
a pris du recul avec la politique c'est
un regret mais c'est aussi un passage de
témoin aujourd'hui il a transmis ses
dires le
le relais à bruno retailleau aussi qui
fait partie de ces nouveaux visages des
personnes qui sont très entreprenante
très dans l'esprit de partage qui
souhaitent renouveler les visages de la
politique il l'a fait au niveau de son
conseil d'administration
en récupérant j'allais dire quatre
membres du groupe edf qui participe on
va dire aujourd'hui au conseil
d'administration pour qu'on est content
on sait qu'aujourd'hui les actions qu'on
mène sont entendus au plus haut point
déjà chez forces républicaines donc pour
moi aujourd'hui je vais dire un petit
regret mais je suis content parce que ça
fait partie aujourd'hui de ce que les
français attendent le renouvellement
c'est bien enclenché pour vous connaître
un petit peu mieux j'aimerais savoir les
personnages politiques qui qui vous
inspire un petit peu à laurianne général
de gaulle forcément oui
au-delà de ça j'en ai un autre début de
ma carrière politique c'était antoine
ruffenach le maire du havre parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui est parti d'une
ville communiste qui était quand même
très très ancrée on va dire communiste
qui a réussi à convertir une population
qui vote pour toutes les élections
nationales et régionales
toujours à gauche ou à l'extrême gauche
et qui a réussi pendant quatre mandats
stores et on va dire une ville à droite
à faire un développement économique très
réussie à repenser son centre ville et
pour moi c'était quelqu'un que
j'appréciais beaucoup parce qu'il se
mettait pas beaucoup en avant
c'était quelqu'un qu'on
à dire qu'on validé par rapport à ses
résultats et moi c'est une personnalité
qui m'a beaucoup marqué on parle de ses
personnages politiques est ce que il y
en a aussi qui vous ont donné envie de
vous impliquer en politique comme en
effet cet engagement politique page
d'accueil à charles pasqua aussi qui
était quand même un très grand monsieur
qui donnait envie par rapport à ses
combats par rapport au souverainisme
quelqu'un qui ne lâchait pas la faire au
même titre que philippe seguin qui a
quand même transformé on va dire le
modèle politique françois fillon s'en
est largement inspiré pendant sa
campagne
aujourd'hui on a deux modèles
relativement complémentaires l'un plus
sur le champ du combat et de la sécurité
l'autre plus sur le plan on va dire de
l'économie du développement
pour moi c'est aujourd'hui les modèles
qu'il faut suivre votre engagement a
débuté quand à quel âge mon engagement a
commencé à 18 ans j'étais le plus jeune
conseiller municipal des yvelines à
l'époque puisque j'étais élu à noisy le
roi et donc j'étais membre à l'époque de
démocratie libérale et j'avais
été convertis au rassemblement pour la
république de jacques chirac
j'avais commencé effectivement dans la
troisième circonscription des yvelines
en qualité délégué cantonal aux côtés de
philippe brillault et ç'a toujours été à
droite ça a été une évidence toujours
été à droite oui c'était c'était mes
combats c'était mes idées mes
convictions je me retrouvais
effectivement dans les discours qui a
été prononcé je trouvais qu'il y avait
un vrai soulèvement populaire on sentait
que les gens étaient heureux s'est
impliqué dans les actions
quand vous entendez aujourd'hui ni
droite ni gauche que finalement les
partis traditionnels où ça veut plus
dire grand chose
vous dites qu'il faut repenser la
politique ou qu'au contraire on va y
revenir à un moment ou un autre à choses
plus claires politique de droite
politique de gauche
je dirais qu'on est sur une phase
transitoire pour le moment j'ai à dire
de ce que j'ai remarqué c'est
qu'effectivement certains partis
traditionnels vers leurs électeurs parce
qu'ils ont eu assez qu'on leur seront
sortent des mensonges pendant la
campagne je prends le cas des
républicains pour effectivement françois
fillon avait pris un programme très
clair et au moment des législatives le
programme a été abandonnée donc les
personnes se sont dit on s'est moqué de
nous parce qu'on a travaillé sur quelque
chose aujourd'hui on jette aux orties au
niveau du rassemblement pour la france à
partir de ce moment là on a vu le nombre
d'auto édition augmentée
on est passé sur un longue d'une
centaine d'adhésions en l'espace de deux
mois alors que c'était plutôt une
dizaine d'adhésions plus tôt par mois
aujourd'hui on sent qu'elles ont voulu
se rapprocher d'eux d'autres partis plus
proches de leurs intérêts c'est vrai
qu'à force de voir toujours les mêmes
visages qui nous ressort toujours les
mêmes idées
et puis qui ne sont jamais appliquées ça
énerve un petit peu je dirais
aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya des phases de
reconstruction pour certains partis
fallait les enclos chez beaucoup plus
tôt mais je dirais que c'est plutôt les
petits partis qui sont en train de
grandir parce qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui sont plus à l'écouté des
personnes et ces personnes effectivement
qu'ils se sont plus investis dans ces
partis parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
base qui donne des idées au sommet le
sommet effectivement qui les transmet au
début alors qu'avant c'était plutôt les
élus qu elle expliqué à la base pour
quoi ils allaient faire telle ou telle
action
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est plutôt
sur un reponsable de l'outil politique
électorale que les parties n'avaient pas
anticipé de meilleur mois aujourd'hui la
recomposition politique prend aussi du
temps et à l'opposition en tout cas
celle qu'on entend le plus souvent c'est
c'est françois soumises
on entend assez peu la droite finalement
dans les débats oui il faut dire aussi
que la droite est très peu d'invités sur
les médias ça c'est un fait à chaque
fois qu'on demande des passages médias
radio tv only refuse systématiquement on
est gentil pour quelle raison on n'est
pas en odeur de sainteté
c'est un c'est embêtant heureusement les
tv locales nous permettent effectivement
de pouvoir nous exprimer
c'est peut-être que les choses aussi à
droite du national sont pas aussi clairs
que ça parce que bon on va pas
s'attarder sur les républicains mais il
ya beaucoup de voix différentes aussi là
maintenant ça m'a changé puisque il
rappelé voilà un jeu direct aussi le
problème de la représentation des petits
partis effectivement comme on se base à
chaque fois sur un pourcentage
suite aux dernières élections va nous
autoriser un temps de parole et je
dirais que ce temps de parole ba n'est
pas bon parce que forcément on n'est pas
forcément assez audible avec de très
bonnes idées et surtout passer un petit
peu plus de gens de parole je pense que
la population je dirais oui je suis
détournerait de certains partis
traditionnels parce qu'elle te dire eh
ben oui nos réponses ont été écoutés sur
les petits partis mettent les petits
partis vont devenir grand parce
qu'aujourd'hui elles ont les solutions
aujourd'hui pour en revenir à vous
vous n'avez pas de mandat électif non
est ce que c'est une frustration non
justement parce que ça me permet
aujourd'hui j'allais dire de prendre du
temps de travailler avec un certain
nombre de personnalités à créer un sim
temps qui s'appellerait faut aujourd'hui
parrainé par bruno retailleau par hervé
novelli
on a des nouvelles personnalités qui
nous auront rejoint karine charbonnier
entrepreneurs à venir france je vois là
mais je recherchais la signification
partiellement sur corner avec fillon
donc ce think tank ou aujourd'hui où
plusieurs élus de des yvelines on a
notamment alain gournac saynètes
sénateur maire honoraire du cac qui nous
a rejoint pourrait travailler avec nous
sur certaines thématiques on à la prison
de l'atp a donc la fédération des très
petites entreprises digiteo qui nous a
rejoint qui est notre président mais
aujourd'hui effectivement on a réussi à
discuter avec un certain nombre de
sénateurs deux conseillers régionaux
dans toute la france puisque notre
groupe hors groupe après trois mille
personne n'occupe pas encore toutes les
régions là les français de l'étranger
qui sont avec nous
aujourd'hui ça parle davantage dire de
ne pas avoir de mandat c'est que les
personnes se sentent d'égal à égal pour
parler avec nous donc agir sur le
terrain sans avoir de mandat tout à fait
personnes avec deux supériorités je
dirais même c'est même beaucoup plus
évident parce qu'on peut aller au devant
des élus discuter avec eux on leur
apporte un bonus cela veut dire
aujourd'hui c'est à eux effectivement de
l'utiliser convenablement ou pas on le
voit aujourd'hui forces républicaines
est venu vers nous il disant vos idées
sont totalement novatrice on aimerait
bien les intégrer à l'intérieur de notre
micro partis on aimerait bien vous soyez
notre think tank notre force de travail
sur la partie entreprenariale on l'a vu
aussi avec la partie droite libre de
virginie calmels ce qu'ils nous
demandent aussi de travailler aux côtés
de laurent wauquiez sur un paul
entrepreneur puisqu'aujourd'hui c'est ce
qui manque aux républicains la partie
entreprenariale donc aujourd'hui on voit
que notre groupe a effectivement fait
envie ou donne envie eu effectivement de
nous écouter une dernière question est
ce que vous allez mener à d'autres
campagnes
oui déjà c'est prévu c'est prévu pour
2019 pour 2010
vous serez engagé et sur le terrain
engagés sur le terrain tout à fait avec
avec d'autres personnes sur un suspense
incroyable très clair au niveau européen
merci alexandre barrelet dernières
années pour ce café politique
[Musique]
et